- What you're gonna see behind me
is a gauntlet of superstitions.
It doesn't really matter
how superstitious I am
because this is all gonna
be enough to ruin my life.
- The mirror is the one
that I'm like, "Oooo."
- And I know what this is about.
This means I'm not gonna get married.
There will never be a ring on this finger.
- This is so stupid.
- My cat's probably gonna
be dead when I come home.
My girlfriend's gonna break up with me.
I'm gonna lose my job,
what else can happen?
It's a very common
condiment in the household
and I'm just gonna pour
one out for my homies.
- You know why this is probably bad luck
because it's wasteful, that's why.
- Fuck you salt. There it is.
- Not gonna throw it over my shoulder
because that would be the
common sense thing to do.
- [voiceover] No! No, Curly.
- I don't care.
You're not the one that's
gonna die and lose their hair.
- So we've got an umbrella.
- Umbrella is the one that
I think I'm least afraid of
because I don't believe in
umbrellas, I believe in Jesus.
- This one ain't messing me up too bad,
I'm feeling good about this.
The salt thing I'm not
feeling awesome about though.
I really wanna toss that.
- Okay.
I've avoided walking
under ladders all my life.
And there's like a million of them.
- I don't wanna do this.
- (laughing) Oh, man. All right.
- We're just gonna calmly
stroll through the ladders.
- Bye, future. It was nice knowing you.
- Well, I would have to say that this
is probably just dangerous overall.
- Does this mean I'm
gonna have eight husbands?
- Just hanging underneath
all these ladders.
- ♫ I made it.
- And here we are reflection.
- What are the goggles for?
What's gonna protect the rest of me?
What's gonna protect
my spirit and my soul?
- Going out with my
boots on and my shirt off
like a true redneck, how we're doing this.
- Why?
- (laughing) I don't wanna do this.
- If my life is gonna
suck from here on out
this is my aggression to the thing
that's gonna fuck up my life.
- ♫ Oh, sweet lord be with me today.
- Oh.
- (screaming)
(glass shattering)
Fuck my life, that was so
cool, but I'm so scared.
Why do I still have these goggles on?
- Not too shabby, I guess.
(glass breaking)
I just feel like this is
just gonna fly on me though.
(glass shattering)
Today, the angels and whoever is up there
is gonna have to be working extra hard.
We'll see if I'm still alive later on.
(glass shattering)
- Oh shit.
- [voiceover] How was your week?
- Feel like I had an
exceptionally good week.
- The week went by pretty smoothly.
- I'm definitely glad about the experience
because I feel like it
helped me take power away
from those things in a sense.
- When you think something
positive is gonna happen
you make it happen for yourself.
- At the end of the day
it's just the way that you view things.
If somebody were to tell you that
if you actually break a
mirror that's good luck
then you're gonna believe
that it's gonna be good luck
and it's gonna change the
way that you live your life
on a daily I think.
(somber piano)
- I really think this broke
a lot of barriers for me.
I did everything I could
to make my luck awful
and this week was actually pretty good.
- Now, if it was mercury retro-grade,
then that'd be a different story.
Then, I'd be like, "Fuh."
I would never break another mirror again
because maybe bad luck was like, "Oh shit,
they're filming us. I won't
be showing up this round."